Merde !
C'est mieux !
Ça va ?
C'est la dernière, patron.
Ça va aller.
On va te trouver des habits.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- On ne sait pas vraiment.
- On ne sait rien du tout.
FELICITATIONS !
VOUS AVEZ ETE SELECTIONNE !
PREPAREZ-VOUS A VIVRE
L'EXPERIENCE D'UNE VIE !
Ça ne dit pas grand chose.
C'est un ramassis de conneries.
Les joueurs devront obéir
pour ne pas être pénalisés.
Allez ma chérie,
on va te trouver des vêtements.
Allez, viens.
Ils sont très confortables.
VÊTEMENTS
On dirait que c'est toi
la dernière.
Tu dois le prendre, ma chérie.
Où suis-je ?
Évitons les questions
pour l'instant.
Tu peux te changer là-dedans.
Appelle si tu veux un coup
de main, poupée.
Garde ta bite dans ton froc.
Si tu vas aux toilettes,
secoue bien la poignée
quand tu tires la chasse,
sinon elle coule toute la nuit.
Faut juste la secouer un peu.
LES JOUEURS DOIVENT
GARDER LES MAINS PROPRES
Bienvenue, joueur 14.
Une chance incroyable
s'offre à vous.
Vous êtes notre dernière
concurrente, la plus importante.
Le jeu va bientôt commencer.
Gardez vos secrets pour vous.
Les apparences
sont parfois trompeuses.
Et souvenez-vous, seuls ceux
qui ne portent pas de collier
peuvent enfreindre les règles.
Les apparences
sont parfois trompeuses.
Souvenez-vous, seuls ceux
qui ne portent pas de collier
peuvent enfreindre les règles.
Bonne chance.
Qu'est-ce qui nous retient ?
Il faut toujours rester groupé
lors d'une mission de sauvetage.
Il faut sortir d'ici !
- Tu sais ce qui va se passer !
- On ne sait rien !
Je suis avec lui.
Restons ici jusqu'à ce qu'on
comprenne...
Pour finir comme eux ?
Je suis avec toi.
Ils bluffent.
C'est un bluff assez élaboré,
non ?
Si tu réussis, t'es un héros.
Quelle bande de cons.
- Rien ne t'en empêche.
- On ne peut pas rester là.
J'y vais tout de suite !
- Sois raisonnable.
- C'est raisonnable tout ça ?
- Souhaitez-moi bonne chance.
- Ne fais pas ça,
- on va trouver une solution.
- Plus le temps, Lee.
Il faut que quelqu'un agisse.
Les joueurs NE DOIVENT PAS
franchir cette ligne.
Crétins !
C'est des conneries tout ça !
Ils se foutent de nous !
Tu viens ?
Je suis juste derrière toi.
Attends !
S'il te plaît,
emmène-moi avec toi.
Personne d'autre ?
Tout ça c'est un tas de...
Il y a quelqu'un ? Aidez-nous,
je vous en prie !
Alors ?
On dirait qu'ils ne bluffent pas.
Connard !
- C'est quoi ton problème ?
- Quelqu'un est mort !
Fallait bien essayer,
et plutôt lui que moi !
- Quelle merde !
- On ne sortira jamais d'ici !
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- T'en sais autant que nous.
Pas autant. Presque, mais...
Obéir aux règles ou subir
les conséquences.
Maintenant tu en sais autant.
Dit comme ça...
Les conséquences sont plutôt...
Ça fait un choc, non ?
Je ne me souviens pas
comment je suis arrivée là.
Nous non plus.
Pas de mémoire,
les idées confuses.
Juste des numéros
et des couleurs.
Parle-nous un peu de toi.
Tu viens d'où ?
Du Mississpipi.
Où au juste ?
- J'ai des cousins là-bas.
- Starkville.
Ça te manque ?
Pas vraiment. Mais comparé
à ici, c'est le paradis.
Tu m'étonnes.
Comparé à ici, même
un fast-food, c'est le paradis.
Où est passé ton accent ?
On a beaucoup bougé.
Ton nom ?
Tonya. Tonya May.
Tonya May. Quel joli nom.
Tu as un plat préféré ?
- Pardon ?
- C'est quand, ton anniversaire ?
Harry, tu n'as pas mieux
à faire ?
Tu t'habitueras à lui.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans la boîte ?
Ne t'en approche pas.
Il n'y a rien pour toi
là-dedans.
Tonya, tu dois nous
dire quelque chose.
Y avait-il autre chose
avec tes vêtements ?
Une photo, c'est tout.
Une photo de quoi ?
Je vais aller voir Ryth.
Écoute,
on est tous
dans le même sac.
Si tu as besoin
de quelque chose...
Je m'appelle Lee.
Enchanté.
Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
Difficile à dire.
On peut lui faire confiance ?
Mêle-toi de ce qui te regarde.
Je demandais, c'est tout.
Ça t'arrive de...
Non... Bien sûr que non...
INDICE :
Recollez les morceaux.
Les joueurs NE DOIVENT PAS
ajuster leurs colliers.
Salut.
- Ça va ?
- Qu'est-ce que tu veux ?
- Désolée...
- Fais vite.
- Je ne voulais pas...
- Qu'est-ce que tu veux ?
- Où as-tu eu...
- Le briquet ?
Je l'ai trouvé.
J'essaye de...
Tu sais comment
tu es arrivée là ?
Le coup de la petite innocente,
je ne gobe pas.
Lee dit que tu viens
du Mississippi.
- C'est vrai.
- Un état superbe.
Je l'ai traversé avec mon mari,
un gentleman du Sud.
Il disait toujours...
Grand-mère, va écrire
tes mémoires ailleurs.
- Superbe état.
- Merci.
Les gens y sont vraiment
sympathiques.
C'est quoi ton problème ?
L'honnêteté.
Tu n'as pas d'amis ici.
Mets-toi ça vite dans le crâne.
Le jeu va commencer
dans une heure.
- Ça venait d'où ?
- Du plafond, je crois.
Mon Dieu ! Sortez-moi de là !
Génial ! Maintenant les larmes !
Calmez-vous !
On va peut-être enfin
avoir des réponses.
Oui. Les jeux c'est drôle
d'habitude, non ?
Je peux t'aider ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a là-dedans ?
- Tu veux vraiment savoir ?
- On ne peut pas l'ouvrir.
Vraiment ?
Moi je sais ce qu'il y a.
- Quoi donc ?
- Des armes.
- Pour se défendre ?
- Peut-être...
Ou bien pour autre chose.
INDICE :
Le joueur 5 ne dit pas la vérité.
- Ça fait combien de temps ?
- J'en sais rien, Harry.
Ça doit faire presque une heure,
non ?
Tu as sûrement raison.
Le jeu va commencer
dans cinq minutes.
Je le savais. Je te l'avais dit,
pas vrai ?
Rassemblons-nous !
Rappelez-vous,
quoi qu'il arrive,
- il faut qu'on reste soudés.
- Oui, mon capitaine !
J'ai un mauvais pressentiment.
Oui, je sais.
Restez au centre de la pièce !
Là !
Bonjour, et bienvenue
à vous tous.
Nous sommes heureux
que vous puissiez tous être là.
Malheureusement, on dirait
que les joueurs 2, 7 et 12
s'en sont déjà allés.
Il ne serait pas juste de les
laisser partir les mains vides,
nous avons donc préparé
de ravissants cadeaux d'adieu.
Les règles sont les règles,
mes enfants.
Je vous vois là, anxieux de
savoir ce que j'ai à vous dire.
Je vais donc aller droit au but,
le verbe verbeux.
Vous avez tous été choisis
pour participer à un jeu
qui changera votre vie.
Vous devrez choisir votre destin,
ou il sera choisi pour vous.
Il n'y aura qu'un seul
vainqueur.
Il recevra le prix le plus cher
qui puisse exister :
la vie.
La question que vous devrez
vous poser est :
à qui faire confiance ?
Tuer, ou être tué.
Rassemblez les éléments.
Bonne chance à vous tous.
On est morts. On va tous mourir !
Ce n'est pas ce qu'il a dit.
On dirait que c'est fini,
le copinage.
On fait quoi maintenant ?
Je propose
qu'on fasse connaissance.
C'est des foutaises.
Je suis prof.
J'enseigne l'anglais en 6ème.
Je suis mariée,
avec trois enfants.
Émouvante, ton histoire,
bouboule.
Je vous assure.
Je travaille dans l'immobilier.
Moi et mon mari, on dirigeait...
On dirige une agence.
Je suis un ancien alcoolique.
Je travaille dans le social.
Ma femme m'a quitté
il y a vingt ans.
- Je suis désolé.
- Ne le sois pas.
C'est la meilleure chose
qui pouvait m'arriver.
Je suis conseiller téléphonique,
surtout dans le fiscal,
mais pas uniquement.
Que seraient les conseils sans
un peu de soutien émotionnel ?
En juillet, un type m'appelle,
on me le passe,
pour des conseils matrimoniaux.
Je lui dis "Chris",
c'était son nom...
Ou plutôt Craig...
Oui, il s'appelait Craig.
- Ça suffit.
- Je lui dis "Craig,
"je ne sais pas quoi dire.
"On dirait qu'elle ne t'aime
plus." C'est dingue, non ?
Harry ! Ça suffit.
J'aime le chocolat.
Le chocolat noir.
Surtout trempé dans la confiture
à la framboise.
Je suis vendeur
chez un concessionnaire.
- Un concessionnaire de dope ?
- T'as un problème ?
Pas du tout. Cool, mon frère.
Je suis la cadette
de trois enfants,
étudiante en psychologie.
Mes parents ont divorcé
récemment.
Je suis plus proche de ma mère.
Faites chier !
Je m'appelle Charlie,
je suis prêtre jésuite.
Qu'on me fouette sur l'autel !
Charlie, continuez.
C'est tout.
Je suis née aux Pays-Bas.
Mes parents sont venus
en Amérique pendant la guerre.
J'avais huit ans à l'époque.
J'ai rencontré mon mari
à quatorze ans.
Bon, cuisinez-moi.
Commence par nous dire ton nom.
- D'où viens-tu ?
- Dis-moi, chef,
pourquoi c'est toi qui pose
toutes les questions ?
Extinction des feux !
Le couvre-feu commence.
Ne paniquez pas.
Attendons que ça passe.
Lee ?
Tonya, reste où tu es.
C'est quoi cette merde ?
- Mon Dieu !
- Faites-la taire !
Il y a des lampes torches ?
- C'était quoi ?
- Ça va ?
Il y avait quelqu'un
dans la pièce.
- J'ai vu quelque chose.
- Quoi donc ?
Un indice. "Patience".
On était d'accord,
on ne touche pas aux armes.
- Les règles ont changé.
- Comment vas-tu l'ouvrir ?
Tu avais la clé ?
- Tu veux m'en empêcher ?
- Ne fais pas ça !
Lee a raison,
il faut rester unis !
Je prends une assurance,
c'est tout.
- Il est chargé ?
- Bien sûr.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
La mettre avec les autres.
Les autres ?
Ils ont enfreint les règles.
Qu'est-ce qu'il a fait, lui ?
Il ne s'est pas lavé les mains.
Tu déconnes ?
INDICE:
Le quatorze est la clé.
C'était dégueulasse, hein ?
Plutôt flippant.
C'est quand ton anniversaire ?
- Pourquoi ça t'intéresse tant ?
- Pour rien.
D'accord, je vais te le dire.
Je compile les infos.
Je fais une liste,
j'essaie de trouver un lien.
Des indices ?
Un peu.
Le 11 et le 18
ont le même anniversaire.
Le 10 et le 13 sont
tous les deux noirs.
- Tu es ici depuis quand ?
- Difficile à dire.
Je ne sais même pas si je
pourrais le dire. Le temps...
Depuis quand ?
Tu devrais demander à Charlie.
C'est le premier arrivé.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Je ne peux rien dire
pour l'instant.
- Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
- Ça va aller.
On est coincés.
Mais on cherche un moyen
de s'évader.
Ça va aller.
INDICE:
MÉLANGEZ
Ça va aujourd hui ?
- J'ai vu mieux.
- Tu as bonne mine.
- Tu me fais du gringue ?
- Je peux me joindre à toi ?
Ça dépend de tes intentions.
Pourquoi nous donner
une arme sans munitions ?
Ce n'est pas logique.
Comme le reste.
C'est quoi à ton avis ?
Ça sent le Happy Hour.
Je n'ai jamais fait de mal.
Je suis une bonne chrétienne.
Donc le seigneur te protègera.
Pourquoi personne
ne nous a retrouvés ?
Mon mari a dû remarquer
mon absence.
- Où est la police ?
- Reste calme, ça va aller.
Non, je ne le crois pas !
Et eux, ils ont l'air
d'aller bien ?
Et moi,
j'ai l'air d'aller bien ?
J'en ai ras-le-bol qu'on me dise
que ça va aller.
Alors arrête d'essayer
de me rassurer !
Du calme, ma chérie.
Ton heure n'est pas venue.
Extinction des feux.
Le couvre-feu commence.
Seigneur, on va tous mourir !
- Restez où vous êtes !
- Ça a marché la dernière fois !
J'ai vu quelque chose, Lee !
Il y a quelque chose !
Qui a fait ça ?
Qui est le coupable ?
- Tu es resté là, comme ça ?
- Non, elle...
Répondez-moi !
Elle me protégeait !
- Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
- "Terrorise-le". Cet enfoiré !
Tu aimes regarder ?
Je vais faire le spectacle.
Viens te battre comme un homme !
- Arrête Henry !
- Sors et bats-toi !
Tu veux me tuer ?
Alors viens le faire !
- Henry, on a besoin de toi !
- J'en ai marre !
Tout ça, c'est pas normal Lee !
Je sais, mais on a quand même
besoin de toi !
Ressaisis-toi !
C'est pas normal !
Tout ça...
- On a besoin de toi.
- C'est pas normal !
Je connais ça.
Tu sais...
Si tu as besoin de quelque chose,
tu peux m'en parler.
Ou je peux te parler.
Comme tu veux.
Accroche-toi, mon pote.
Un anagramme !
Tu as lu le message ?
Alors ?
DANS LE MIROIR
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
QUEL EST VOTRE TYPE D'HOMME ?
IL Y EN A 3 ICI.
UN VIOLEUR,
UN PEDOPHILE ET UN TUEUR.
TROUVEZ L'ASSASSIN,
VOUS TROUVEREZ LE MOTIF.
Je crois qu'on va tenir
une autre réunion.
Il est parmi nous, tu sais.
- Comment ça ?
- Le tueur.
Enfin...
C'est forcément l'un d'entre nous.
Comment le sais-tu ?
C'est le but du jeu, non ?
Je ne crois pas.
On ne sait rien
de ces personnes.
Tu crois pouvoir leur faire
confiance ?
Je te le dis, je ne me fie
à aucun d'entre eux.
Il y a au moins un tueur
parmi nous.
On a essayé de l'arrêter.
Laissez-le.
Bon, écoutez tous.
Avant que je ne m'explique,
quelqu'un se sent-il
le besoin de se confesser ?
Moins fort !
Commençons par toi. Tu as
quelque chose à nous dire ?
Je te le demande encore une fois.
Tu nous caches quelque chose ?
J'ai quelque chose à dire.
Je ne suis pas conseiller fiscal.
Je suis au chômage
et je vis chez ma mère.
- Tu as menti ?
- Non.
Enfin si.
Mais j'ai travaillé comme
conseiller, puis les Indiens,
ceux avec le point,
pas avec les plumes...
On m'a viré et j'ai dû
m'installer chez ma mère,
et c'est horrible
parce qu'elle sort
avec un type dans mes âges
et qui me force à l'appeler papa !
Et je ne veux pas faire ça !
D'accord, ça va. Merci.
Personne d'autre ?
J'ai volé dix dollars à ma mère
quand j'avais cinq ans.
D'accord. Merci.
Dis ce que tu as à dire.
On a trouvé quelque chose.
Un message.
Dans cette pièce,
il y a un meurtrier,
un violeur et un pédophile.
Ça alors !
Ça ne veut rien dire.
Il essaye peut-être
de nous embrouiller.
Attendez, j'ai trouvé.
Charlie, tu es prêtre ?
- En effet.
- Pédophile.
Attendez voir...
- Le violeur.
- Enfoiré !
Connard, je vais te massacrer !
- Les gars !
- Fais gaffe à toi !
Ça suffit !
Ne le laissez pas
s'approcher de moi !
C'est quoi ?
C'est une petite fille.
C'est ma petite-fille !
Joueur 10 a brisé les règles,
donc les règles vont le briser.
Vous allez témoigner
d'un défi très spécial.
Joueur 10 a une minute
pour éliminer un concurrent.
Mon Dieu, non !
Allons bon,
le pédophile a peur !
Quoi ? C'est faux !
- Je ne pourrais jamais...
- Vous pouvez commencer.
J'ai une famille
et trois enfants !
Qu'est-ce que tu as fait
à ces enfants ?
Comment osez-vous ?
Ce sont mes enfants !
- Jamais je ne...
- Comment as-tu...?
- Où as-tu trouvé ça, Henry ?
- Avec l'uniforme.
- Tu n'es pas obligé.
- Je n'ai pas le choix.
- Tu as le choix !
- C'est mon bébé, j'ai pas le choix !
C'est un mensonge,
- je le jure ! Je vous en prie !
- C'est mon bébé là-haut.
C'est un mensonge !
- Désolé.
- Je le jure !
Je n'ai pas le choix !
C'est mon bébé !
Je n'ai pas le choix,
vous comprenez ?
Aidez-moi !
Pardonnez-moi, tout le monde !
Henry ! Oh mon Dieu !
Ça va. Tout va bien.
Tu n'es pas responsable.
Ça va. Tu n'es pas responsable.
Tu n'aurais rien pu faire.
J'ai quelque chose à te montrer.
On sait qui tu es, bouboule.
Et si tu n'es pas le pédophile,
tu dois donc être le meurtrier,
n'est-ce pas ?
- Je ne suis pas un meurtrier.
- Il va falloir faire mieux.
Recollez les morceaux.
Il y a autre chose.
Bienvenue, joueur 14.
Une chance incroyable
s'offre à vous.
Vous êtes notre dernière
concurrente,
la plus importante.
Le jeu va bientôt commencer.
Gardez vos secrets.
Les apparences peuvent être
trompeuses.
Et souvenez-vous, seuls ceux
qui ne portent pas de collier
peuvent enfreindre les règles.
Bonne chance.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ici ?
- Où étiez-vous tous les deux ?
- On le ligote.
- C'est le meurtrier, Lee.
- On ne ligote personne !
- La majorité a parlé, chef.
- Il est sérieux ?
Lee, on doit se protéger.
C'est logique.
Vous pouvez me ligoter.
Je n'ai rien à cacher.
Tu vois ?
Même lui est contre toi.
Du calme !
- Vous ne pouvez pas faire ça !
- Tu dois écouter !
Arrêtez !
Elle est morte.
- On tombe comme des mouches.
- Harry, ligote-le.
- Tu ne vas pas leur parler ?
- Pour dire quoi ?
- Pas trop serré j'espère.
- Je suis innocent. Vous verrez.
Extinction des feux.
Le couvre-feu commence.
"Si votre ennemi a faim,
donnez-lui à manger.
"S'il a soif, donnez-lui à boire.
"Car vous amasserez
des charbons de feu sur sa tête,
"et le Seigneur vous justifiera."
Merde.
- Mon Dieu !
- Tu es content ?
"Les joueurs 1 et 3 sont partis,
mais le meurtrier et le violeur
sont toujours là."
- Comment est-ce possible ?
- Merde !
Donne-moi ton stylo.
Tonya a une clé.
J'étais sûr qu'elle cachait
quelque chose !
Elle ouvre peut-être un collier.
Tonya, fais diversion.
Espèce de connard !
Laisse-moi sortir !
L'autre caméra est cassée,
Harry n'est plus dans le champ.
Il faut donc aller là-bas
un par un.
Si l'un d'entre nous
arrive à l'enlever ?
Ça veut dire qu'on n'est plus
restreint.
- Qu'est-ce qui te fait dire ça ?
- Ferme ta gueule !
Il y a ça.
Bienvenue, joueur 14.
Une chance incroyable
s'offre à vous.
On dirait que je suis
le dernier.
Et si la clé était destinée
à l'un des autres ?
Elle ne nous servirait plus à rien.
Et maintenant, patron ?
- On fait quoi ?
- Donne-moi un peu de temps.
On n'a pas de temps !
On est enfermé avec un tueur !
Encore quelques extinctions
et il ne restera plus personne.
En fait...
Il en restera un.
- Tu leur fais confiance ?
- Qu'est-ce que tu proposes ?
Faites ce que vous voulez.
Je vais agir à ma façon.
Il faut l'économiser !
- Pour le prochain enterrement ?
- Tout est ici pour une raison.
Un lien. Oui, il faut trouver...
Quand allez-vous comprendre
qu'il n'y a pas de lien !
Ce type s'amuse avec nous,
et nous, on joue le jeu !
Il a raison. On va tous mourir.
- C'est ça, résignons-nous.
- Ça suffit !
- Tu as un problème ?
- Oui.
- J'en ai marre de ta gueule !
- Très bien.
- Viens, mon pote !
- Ouais, viens !
Ça fait un moment
que j'attendais ça.
C'est entre lui et moi, Lee.
- Finissons-en.
- Quand tu veux.
- Qu'est-ce que t'as fait ?
- C'était un tout petit coup.
Quoi, je lui ai juste fait peur.
C'est lui qui m'a attaqué !
Il ne respire plus.
J'ai seulement...
Je ne ferais jamais...
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
- Du poison.
- Du poison ?
Oui, c'était dans la boîte.
- Non, je n'ai jamais vu...
- Tu l'as empoisonné !
- Et le numéro 3 aussi !
- Ne me regarde pas comme ça.
- Il est mort !
- Je ne suis pas un assassin !
Ne me regardez pas comme ça !
Merde !
Vous êtes un groupe
très divertissant.
Meilleurs que les précédents.
Préparez-vous, mes enfants.
Une autre surprise vous attend.
Merde ! Harry,
tu m'as foutu la trouille !
J'ai entendu quelque chose.
- Il y a quelqu'un !
- Quoi ?
Allumez les lumières !
C'est qui ?
J'en sais rien.
Il n'a qu'à nous le dire.
Qui es-tu ?
- Tentons autre chose.
- T'en as assez fait !
Vous allez me tuer ?
- Ne me tuez pas.
- On n'est pas des assassins.
Du moins, pas tous.
Où suis-je ?
Dans un hangar.
- Et si la clé marchait sur lui ?
- Qui êtes-vous ?
Je suis le 6, et toi ?
Moi c'est Lee, elle c'est Tonya.
- Moi c'est Harry.
- Je ne comprends rien.
C'est simple. On sort d'ici
ou bien on meurt.
Une suggestion ?
Détache-le, Harry.
On ne devrait pas le connaître
mieux d'abord ?
Oui, je crois qu'il a raison.
Très bien.
Ton nom ?
Robert comment ?
Tanner. Robert Tanner.
- D'où viens-tu ?
- Los Angeles.
Tu fais quoi dans la vie ?
Du droit. Je viens de passer
le barreau.
C'est sûr qu'il est honnête !
- As-tu déjà tué quelqu'un ?
- Quoi ? Non !
Satisfait ?
Très bon interrogatoire.
Je peux essayer ?
Pourquoi tu es ici,
et comment on a atterri là ?
- Je vous ai tout dit !
- Je ne comprends pas bien !
Je me suis endormi dans mon lit,
et au réveil, vous étiez là
à me regarder !
Mon Dieu ! Je vous en prie.
Maintenant je suis satisfait.
T'es un vrai connard.
Essayons de comprendre
ce que tu fais là.
C'est qui ? C'était...
Une autre concurrente.
Tout ça,
c'est une espèce de jeu ?
On dirait.
Qui fait ça ?
On t'a donné quelque chose ?
- Je ne comprends pas.
- Dans ta poche.
Désolé de ne pas être
plus utile.
Comment tu te sens ?
Mieux. Merci.
Tant mieux.
J'ai quelque chose à te dire.
Quoi ?
Vous vous êtes demandé
ce que veut cet hôte,
comme vous l'appelez ?
- Tu lui fais confiance ?
- Non.
C'est qui à ton avis ?
Il pose trop de questions.
Robert, on va avoir besoin
de ton aide.
- Quel genre d'aide ?
- Oui, quel genre ?
La clé.
Quoi, encore ? Quand est-ce que
tu vas comprendre ?
- Le sien peut être différent.
- Tu veux parier ?
- Que voulez-vous que je fasse ?
- Laisse-nous essayer ça.
Attendez...
C'est maintenant
- Sinon, on est tous morts.
- Robert, je t'en prie.
J'y crois pas !
Cours et ne t'arrête pas
avant de trouver un téléphone.
Appelle les flics et dis-leur
tout ce qui se passe.
- D'accord !
- S'il te plaît.
Robert ?
Il y a un mur.
- Quoi ?
- Il n'y a pas de porte.
Il n'y a qu'un mur.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Reviens.
J'ai trouvé ça.
C'est quoi ?
INDICE :
Serrez les dents.
"Serrez les dents".
- Il ne manquait plus que ça.
- Absolument.
Ça ne va pas arranger
les choses.
Peut-être pas les vôtres,
mais moi, je joue pour gagner.
Tu es sûr que c'était un mur ?
Il faisait sombre,
mais c'était bien un mur.
Il était solide ?
- En plâtre ou en béton ?
- J'en sais rien.
J'ai tapé dessus, il semblait
moins épais que ces murs-ci.
Ça n'a aucun sens !
Pourquoi nous donner la clé
d'une sortie condamnée ?
Parce qu'ils jouent avec nous !
On ne peut pas abandonner,
on est si près !
Laisse tomber, Harry.
Il n'y a qu'un mur. On doit
pouvoir faire quelque chose !
On le fait sauter.
Et avec quoi, Einstein ?
La poudre.
- Tu crois que ça va marcher ?
- Je l'espère, Harry.
- Tout est prêt.
- Sûr ?
Certain.
Donne.
Priez.
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- Ça a foiré, voilà.
- J'ai fait comme tu avais dit.
- Peut-être...
- Je vais jeter un coup d'œil ?
- Je t'en prie !
Ça a marché, les gars !
Bon, reviens Robert.
Attendez !
Vous n'allez pas y croire.
Le jeu ! Ce n'est pas
ce que vous croyez !
- C'est quoi ?
- Tout ça, c'est...
Extinction des feux.
Le couvre-feu commence.
- Mon Dieu !
- Le jeu est quoi ?
Crache le morceau !
Il y a une pièce...
Ce n'est pas lui...
Qui est-ce ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Je crois que...
Mince. Je saigne.
Félicitations.
Vous avez atteint le round final,
doté du meilleur prix,
où les plus grands secrets
sont révélés.
Quel dommage !
Vous étiez si près du but.
Qui pourrait commettre
un acte pareil !
Si je m'écoutais, je dirais
que l'un d'entre vous
ne souhaitait pas partir.
Mais qui est-ce ?
Il a essayé de me tuer !
C'est lui le coupable !
Il s'est rué sur moi.
Je me défendais.
Regardez ce qu'il m'a fait !
C'est lui l'assassin !
- Donne-moi le flingue.
- Il a essayé de me tuer !
Recule ! Il m'en reste assez
pour vous trois !
On discute, d'accord ?
Pose ton arme.
- Reste où tu es !
- C'est lui, je te le dis !
C'était pas moi !
Je te donne une dernière chance.
Je vous tuerai tous
s'il le faut !
Pose ton arme !
Oblige-moi.
Il était temps qu'on lui ferme
sa gueule !
Je suis sûr qu'il est
dans le coup depuis le début.
Regardez-le maintenant !
- Comment tu te sens, Harry ?
- Génial !
Alors ferme-la !
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant ?
Je vais nettoyer ça.
Occupe-toi d'Harry.
- Comment tu te sens ?
- Pas génial.
Tu as de la chance
qu'il n'ait atteint que le bras.
Ça aurait pu être bien pire.
Ça risque de piquer un peu.
Je t'avais prévenu.
Ça va. Tu as les mains douces.
Appuie sur la blessure.
Salut.
Ça n'a pas pris non plus.
Cette arme est vide.
Tu en es certain ?
Ça va.
Tu vas t'en sortir.
On y va ?
Du calme, Lee.
Il ne faut pas t'en vouloir.
Oui, bien sûr.
Profitez bien du spectacle,
monsieur.
- On a ce qu'il nous faut ?
- Comme d'habitude.
Par ici, ma chère.
Alors, qu'est-ce que tu
en penses ?
Il s'en est fallu de peu.
On va bientôt avoir besoin
de toi en salle 3.
J'y vais tout de suite.
Madame, ça va ?
Vous allez bien ?